which one of this guy's movies do you
want to see created as its own virtual
world Oh
mmm good question thank you a good
question
oh right good one I would love to put my
mouth on Jude Law's mouth let's not talk
about find another director did take you
through that experience again okay a lot
of nautical fabulousness happening there
I love it what about you which one of my
movies what I like - you need a virtual
thing because you kind of got to see
this one in a virtual way well if there
was ever that technology available to
convert to movie - and a hundred percent
virtual experience it would have to be
for me Jurassic Park you're so brave
there are dinosaurs there you know
that's right they'll be even bigger
dinosaurs in the virtual world I don't
understand why people keep wanting to go
into Jurassic Park it's like Bros it is
not gonna end well no it never ends well
but that's what's fun it's it's being
able to predict how it's not gonna end
well
something's always goes wrong in those
movies it's Dirk yeah I really like it
I I was picking out tons of details from
the movie and I feel like every one of
them could have a meaning so very
quickly I noticed that on your Sixers
outfit there was the number six six five
one nine Oh was that just a number or
did it have any kind of significance
that's that's that's a secret to be
unlocked by the audience okay good I'm
glad that I said something then so
everybody watching can I love it yeah
okay I saw a Mad Max post-it on the desk
at the end of the movie I don't want to
reveal where it was very heaven you get
to see it twice right oh thank you is
there a reason that Mad Max was there I
mean other than the fact that Mad Max is
awesome in general well Mad Max has a
lot of parallels - ready player one
you know it's a journey it's a chase
it's a race there's a goal in all of
them and so it's you know Mad Max is of
its it it's evocative of what we did
here is there a character that you guys
want people to look for towards the end
when there's a like kind of a big deal
going on I don't really want to reveal
but there's so much to see in the film
can we give people some guidance I think
we could say the Iron Giant because he's
in all the trailers and I think that's
one character at least I have a very
sentimental connection with and I'm sure
a lot of people have the same as I do so
to see him in inside of ready player one
and to see him battling and being on the
side of all the Gunter's and fighting
Iowa was awesome yeah but still having
that sweetness I don't know so just died
when his eyes get all sad I know and
they do you know I think but I think we
project our own sadness at his plight
into his eyes because his eyes can only
go half mass with the lids they don't
they don't have a cat they don't they
don't morph into expression what Steven
Spielberg movie would I like to bring to
life is a virtual reality world Wow
right I want I won't do that with
Jurassic Park you're bold yeah there are
dinosaurs there I know but assume I
can't get eaten for real for hmm
I feel like maybe the people of Jurassic
Park also felt like they got eaten
well I'm Jeff Goldblum yes let me be him
if you're gonna be anybody in Jersey
Goldblum you go boom Oh God tell me
everything about H please I really think
the character is so layered you know
because I remember asking a Stevens like
why does she choose to you know be a guy
in the Oasis and you really kind of let
me navigate that on my own because the
truth is I think she wants to just be
one of the guys she wants to be treated
equally which is such a really topical
thing right now is that women one
equality we want to be treated just like
a guy would be and I think there's such
a real underlying message there that
when she's in the Oasis and she wants to
just kind of have fun and do her thing
she needs to be a dude and she's a she's
intimidating to you know she's like six
feet tall half you know machine but the
personality is the same you know when
you meet her in the real world but she
had I think she was kind of wants to be
like everyone else and I think that's
interesting that she'd used to be a male
she could do everything that everybody
else can do yeah which is absolutely a
hundred percent real life I don't know
it's so great and I'm really grateful
that a lot of people there's obviously
people know the book very well and
obviously I've read it many times so it
was really nice and people say hey I
heard you're playing H I got really
excited I know great because it could've
been this better than the alternative
but I had a lot of fun with the
character and and also to the by
language is really different you know
what I most capture for my avatar my
body language is very unique than it is
and you know as Helen in the real world
so we have really wonderful acting
coaches on set just to help us with the
body language and to make sure we move
differently you know when I was ironing
I had to change that up because I'm it's
a it's the character a little bit more
gentle and and obviously quiet and so I
had to move a little bit slower I had to
when I'm like fall down to become a
human bridge I have to be very careful
with that and so I'm really grateful to
the acting
- Stephen - really help guide me through
all these different characters it seems
to me like you going into this had a lot
of [ __ ] you had a lot to think about
bringing all that character is there
like a little secret part of H that you
created maybe backstory wise to channel
into this performance you say well for
me when I saw like early pictures of
what the avatar would look like I
immediately thought mr. t and Ice Cube
so those were the pictures I had in my
hotel I would look at every day and
channel those guys because I think
they're cool they're fly and then also I
got to hear they were working on
tweaking my voice as age and it's on
this reminded me Ice Cube a little bit
so Steven was cool let me run with that
it was really really helpful and at the
end of the day did you ever look in the
mirror and be like today was a good day
I do it every day first person to find
the egg will inherit half a trillion
dollars and total control of the Oasis
itself you guys ever had like an awesome
like chat name or gamer name well I
think it's awesome but my I haven't had
a game of name but I remember I was
called sweet sugar that's right I know
there's one of my kind of logins I like
it and I deem it dope yeah I've been
rocking the same names for decades not
revealing that so it's like you could be
gaming with Ben Mendelsohn and not even
know it kind of yeah it's really
exciting
bossman what movie of Spielberg's would
you like to see turn into a virtual
reality world I got it poltergeist oh my
god yeah I want that scary I'm in a suit
VI - you know what I mean cuz you like
there then I think Joel's a vehicle one
oh damn oh this is like the hardcore
yeah
do you think that you would have like
Richard Dreyfuss the [ __ ] out of that
shark
just a hundred percent though yeah cuz
there are a couple times in the movie
actually where I was like I do not know
what is you and what is a stunt person
and the holy crap it was me i am i have
to say i might do my stunts I love it I
love it I yeah I jumped on that car I
was fighting yeah yeah anyway there is
one particular moment like towards the
end of the film where you get this not
can you compare your character and ready
player one to ghost in the upcoming a
man versus a wasp like what is are they
similar in any way different no they're
not similar every role I play in my in
my life on they're not similar that
different I find a difference with
everything there you go yeah do they
teach you anything like have you kind of
come out on the other side of some
belief by playing these because I mean
they seem very unlike you so you know
it's like yeah I mean it's amazing I
mean I find that playing villainous
roles is it's amazing because you kind
of have to find the good in that
character you have to find the reason
the reason really and and yeah a lot of
times that misunderstood people that's
probably why you want to kick the [ __ ]
out of Jaws the punching bag I
understand you and you're still bad do
you guys have any like gaming rituals
like a pregame ritual and then finally
there is a very strange movie choice for
date night in this film that I don't
want to reveal but I was wondering if
you guys had any kind of random choices
for a date night movie no I see I was
around in the IDS you know officer in
our gentleman was a good that was a good
movie attack for a day
nice I was a little
uh-huh richard gere every time Debra
Winger
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]